je m'étais longtemps posé la question de
savoir comment vous en parlais que vous
dire quoi vous dire mais regardez c'est
le jour j on va se parler aujourd'hui on
va savoir quel samsung galaxy boeuf
achetées en 2022 alors je vous parle
bien évidemment des produits que je
connais tout n'a peut-être d'autres qui
sortiront dans l'année paraîtrait assez
normal il aime bien sortir des nouveaux
écouteurs sam sauvegarde et je vous
présente c'est là il ya quatre modèles
alors le tout premier jeu les 1001
histoires se marrait ce sont les
premiers galaxie boys on va regarder
pour voir un peu d'où on vient et puis
on se souvenir naviguer entre trois
modèles intéressants à savoir à la
galaxie buzz live juste la galaxy s2 si
vous en douterez puis galaxie boxe pro
on a une gamme qui est vraiment
intéressant qui est complète on va tous
détaillé on va regarder qualité audio on
va regarder l'expérience logiciel on va
regarder le confort on a gardé la tenue
on va parler de quoi parlait d'autonomie
on va parler de plein de choses bas donc
a plus à raconter là dessus on se fait
donc aujourd'hui au tour complet pour
savoir quel samsung galaxy 2 achetés en
2022 et on part maintenant
[Musique]
on part de loin quand même regarder on
part de loin ça je vous avais présenté
je suis plus en quelle année c'est lé
premier galaxy boys alors autant la
boîte était très jolie et j'aimais
beaucoup cet effet là et puis ça
marchait vraiment bien autant je trouve
que le côté de l'étui comme ça a
vraiment vieilli par rapport à ce qu'on
a aujourd'hui on a des idées de suite
carey sont beaucoup plus joli plus
élégants ces espèces de petits haricots
valls a changé quand même 1 donc bon
alors après la forme on retrouve
effectivement des petits bols donc on va
passer très rapidement côté historique
parce que c'est sympathique mais c'est
pas ça qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
donc next on met ça de côté aujourd'hui
on est vraiment intéressé par ça en la
première chose qu'on voit et je pense
que vous le voyez vous tout de suite ils
ont harmonisé la forme de leur boîtier
la forme de leur étui pour avoir des
petits et hui un peu comme ça voyez
plutôt sur le carré qui s'ouvre comme
une petite bague il ya un côté un peu
bijoux passé les galaxies boys live et
c'est la même chose qu'on va retrouver
les autres alors après au niveau des
buzz 2 ça c'est plutôt sympa et bien
vous allez avoir une couleur qui va être
assortie à la cour de votre smartphone
par exemple ici regardez je vais vous
montrer la chouette en couleur graphite
je croise espèces de tigres et la g1
s-21 et feu c'est la même couleur donc
le truc est vraiment très sympa
lorsqu'on veut venir rentrer dans
l'écosystème parce que ces produits sont
des produits éco système on va rarement
se dire tiens je vais marcher tout seul
les samsung galaxy bud si à côté de ça
on n'a pas un smartphone de samsung
alors dites vous bien que ces galaxies
buzz ils vont tous fonctionné sur
android mais également sur ios mais il
est évident que la vraie bonne
expérience ici à voir c'est avec un
smartphone android et si vous avez un
smartphone de samsung c'est encore mieux
pour toute la notion d'écosystème voit
tout simplement c'est à vous aurez la
meilleure expérience également à faire
tourner avec une watch de samsung vous
aurez un truc qui est vraiment
intéressant et puis là vous avez ensuite
vous le voyez sur le modèle
professionnel pareil qui de couleur
noire tout assorti alors bon on va
commencer par le commencement on va
commencer à se parler des gammes à se
parler des prix et c'est tout comprendre
galaxie buzz live que vous avez juste
ici c'est un produit qui quand il est
sorti écoutée elle voulait doter 149
euros aujourd'hui il coûte plus que 99
euros et je vais vous le détailler mais
le 149 euros non non pour moi c'était
vraiment trop cher en suisse sont
arrivés les galaxies buzz de la peau qui
sont assorties également à 149 euros
alors lisez sur le tarif 149 euros pour
moi c'est vraiment bien aujourd'hui on
peut les trouver tout ça c'est des
promotions site de samsung dont je vous
ai mis le lien en bas dans la
description aller jeter un oeil 129
euros et ça c'est très cool et c'est
vraiment bien positionné et ensuite
c'est le modèle professionnel qui compte
il est sorti et est à 229 euros est là
en ce moment le trouve à 179 euros sur
le site de samsung il peut y avoir des
prix différents en fonction des
revendeurs sur lesquels vous allez moi
je vous mets le lien pour aller
directement chez samsung comme ça vous
êtes peinard vous êtes chez le
constructeur est tout va bien donc voilà
un peu la gamme qu'on va venir
travailler aujourd'hui c'est à dire un
produit à moins de 100 euros un produit
à peu près à 130 euros et un produit à
peu près 180 euros alors on va essayer
de dégrossir essayer de comprendre alors
au delà des boîtes qui sont différentes
sympathique c'est pas un beau sac noir
plus nous intéressait tout ce qui nous
intéresse réellement et bien c'est sur
ces petits boîtiers alors je vous le dis
d'un point de vue extérieur les étuis
sont exactement les mêmes petits
boîtiers petit écrin alors le truc qui
est vraiment différent pour le coup et
vous allez vous en rendre compte très
rapidement son la forme des bugs ça qui
fait vraiment la différence ça cette
galaxie buzz life alors c'est pas
forcément le produit que je vais venir
commander alors sauf si vous voulez
vraiment à voir absolument un buzz de
samsung il côté écosystèmes ça me tente
bien ici on est à 99 euros est à 99
euros je vais trouver des choses plus
intéressantes je pense notamment aux
erwan de nothing que j'ai préféré en
termes de qualité audio mais également
en termes de tenue alors cela ils ont
une particularité qui est assez marrante
c'est que voyez ils viennent se poser
son sac à venir directement dans votre
oreille des petits haricots en fait vous
le prenez je vais essayer de zoomer vous
prenez il se glisse comme ça dans
l'oreille en fait vous le posez vous le
tournez légèrement il rentre dans votre
oreille c'est très simple à venir
positionné au départ être pour l'autre
son petit frère alors on le prend hop on
tourne et voilà on est positionné donc
en termes de positionnement c'est très
très facile en terme de tenue aussi haut
placé celle là qu'il faut tourner en
terme de tenue ça tourne ça tient
vraiment bien on peut y aller on peut
bouger là dessus j'ai pas de problème
donc la tenue est très très bonne en
terme de confort et d'installations et
de positionnement par l'autre à regarder
maintenant les galaxies baisse de 11,2
c'est différent parce que j'ai voulu
mettre là vous avez ici ce petit
silicone qui vient se positionner ya
différentes tailles donc là vous le
prenez ce pas et vous le mettez comme
des thibaud dufoy qu'il est dedans ou
tourner ça sonne très facilement c'est
très très très facile à venir à
positionner voilà là on a également une
réduction de bruit pas si c'est axa
vient vous boucher les oreilles c'est
pas comme des airs pop ce que vous
voulez poser tout simplement sur le côté
donc là ça vient effectivement me
boucher l'oreille mais comme la
réduction de bruit active on peut venir
amplifier le son environnement on
regarde dans quelques instants nous
voyez c'est pareil au niveau du confort
ça fonctionnera et là dessus y'a pas de
soucis puis on va continuer avec les
bugs prot lors les bottes ce procès une
forme qui encore un peu différente on va
voir un embout toujours en silicone
qui a chaussé du silicone cette partie
là qui positionner là il ya différentes
tailles il vient de la même manière se
positionnait assez facilement on prend
en tourne alors tout simplement pareil
dans notre oreille on prend on envoyait
en fait on a form factor qui sont très
très proches le galaxy s ii et galaxy s
pro en termes de confort en terme de
tenue je les fais un peu moins bien
tenir les pros je pense que c'est ptet
pas trouvé est pas bien pu y aller pas
assez tourné voilà je trouve qu'ils
tiennent un peu moins bien c'est juste
une question en fait de taille il faut
vraiment vous trouviez la bonne taille
mais je sais pas pourquoi je préfère
très honnêtement un mois la tenue des
galaxies buzz 2 les galaxy 2 live je
trouve pas mal mais je suis vraiment un
peu moins fan de l'histoire après en
terme de poids c'est quasiment la même
chose à on est à 5 g ici on à 5,6 g ici
là on est quoi 600 et 6,3 g un peu plus
lourd au niveau du modèle pro les
coloris joué bon parce que c'est aussi
un truc important alors les galaxy 2
live on était sur la couleur bronze là
qu'on retrouvait avec d'autres
smartphones de samsung mais c'est une
couleur qui commence un peu à passer
alors si vous aimez pas le bronze peut
retrouver également en blanc et en noir
auquel cas ça fonctionnera très bien si
vous les voulez le bronze était très
typé bon ok les galaxy 2 2 a une fois de
plus très sympa tous blancs et puis vous
y retrouvons star intérieur la couleur
qui ressemble à croire vos smartphones
alors ici on a quoi on a de l'eau livre
du graphite comme ça on a dû la vendre
et puis on a du blanc tandis que sur le
modèle pro et bien vous avez du noir du
viol et du gris du blanc broquet ça
fonctionnera là dessus y'a pas de soucis
au niveau des galaxies boys like vous
avez déjà une réduction de bruit passif
qui a ses forces à celles vraiment bien
vous boucher les oreilles et vous avez
en plus une réduction de bruit active
sinon à 99 euros paraît en tout cas ce
que vient de proposer nothing avec ses
ikhwan on a effectivement aussi comme
ici une réduction de bruit active mais
je vais préférer la qualité audio mais
ça je vous en reparle dans quelques
instants aux grosses différences qui est
important c'est qu'il va vraiment venir
apporter en terme d'expérience passer
toute la partie audio vous avez deux
grosses différences d'un côté vous à
galaxy bud light dans chaque buzz vous
avez un petit transducteurs vous avez un
12 mm dans chaque transducteurs vous en
avez un et un seul qui servira à faire
l'ensemble du spectre c'est-à-dire à
couvrir les fréquences graves et les
fréquences aiguës tandis que sur les
autres c'est à dire les beliebers
probable à vous avez deux transducteurs
qui serviront pour d'un côté les
fréquences graves et un autre qui
travaillera pour les fréquences aiguës
permet d'aller plus loin au niveau de la
répartition du spectre et d'améliorer la
qualité alors ça fait pas tout mais
malgré tout on sent quand même vraiment
la différence entre d'un côté buzz live
le côté boys boys boys from vous avez
tous les côtés trois micros à chaque
fois deux micro externe et un micro
interne s'est plaint réduction de bruit
active comment ça marche je fais très
rapidement en fait vous avez un micro
qui va venir analyser tous le sont
extérieures qui va analyser le sont à
l'intérieur de votre oreille et qui va
en déduire bon ben je connais le son qui
ad'ailleurs l'aurait donc je connais la
musique qui vient je connais le sont à
l'extérieur donc je vois le son qui
viennent l'extérieur je peux bien le
comparer à ce qu'à l'intérieur de
l'oreille je viens annulé tout le son
extérieur qui arrive à passer
intérieurement nos oreilles pendant
système dehors phase hop on n'en parle
plus terminer comme ça on est tranquille
donc ça c'est le principe de la
réduction de bruit active c'est pour ça
que vous avez ces trois micros sur ces
buzz là en terme de qualité audio
purement et simplement pour être très
claire les galates sibbles live je les
aime pas je ne sais même pas parce que
je trouve qu'on a un son qui n'est pas
précis dans l'aigu je trouve très
étouffé et je trouve qu'on a des graves
qui sont pas beaux en fait et c'est pour
ça je peux pas venir vous les
recommandés alors effectivement ces
galaxies buzz live ils sont à 99 euros
mais je voulais des 99 euros vous aurez
chocs sont plus intéressantes allez voir
xiaoping et des choses intéressantes
aussi du côté de chez lg mais je pense
pas que ce soit le modèle le plus réussi
au niveau de l'audio chez samsung donc
cela j'ai tendance à dire ok il existe
si vraiment vous voulez du samsung 100%
500 go de l'écosystème ils sont là mais
pour moi expérience audio n'est pas
vraiment à la hauteur et je préfère
ajouter de l'argent pour arriver sur les
galaxies buzz de parce que là c'est
vraiment autre chose on commence à
arriver à caen son qui va déjà beaucoup
lieu des médiums aigus beaucoup plus
précis on va manquer un peu de rondeur
dans les graves mais on peut venir
corriger qu'une application et sajoo le
monde en quelques instants alors autant
je peux venir corriger certaines choses
améliorer un peu autant là les aigus que
j'éprouve pas bien et crée je peux bien
effet qu'est donc je les ai pas je les
aurais pas voilà je peux venir ajouter
un peu de rondeur mais c'est sûr que la
meilleure expérience avec un peu plus de
précision et plus de dynamique je
récupérerai au niveau des galaxy s pro
on s'en doutera cerveau des
professionnels il va coûter un peu plus
cher mais pour moi ici en tout cas de ce
que je vois c'est voilà à partir des 2 2
c'est intéressant le reste lui plus on
met de côté alors il ya des trucs qui
est intéressant c'est l'autonomie alors
on se doutera que plus on en a et plus
tôt nous vivons une basse parce qu'ici
on a exactement les mêmes batteries
alors à titre d'info sur les galaxy 2
live vous avez une batterie de 60
millions terreur par écouteurs c'est
pareil la cdu 61 au niveau de vos buzz
et les étuis font tous 472 donc en fait
c'est la même chose du point de vue
matériel mais la différence est vaste
aire a pris au niveau du calcul et plus
vous allez en avoir est forcément plus
l'autonomie sera basse ici on va avoir
une très très bonne autonomie aux
équations du cisr par b 21h pareil je
suis ok sur les buzz 2 je vais arriver
sur du saint coeur arm bugs et 20h avec
l'étui ici on se parle avec une
réduction de bruit active forcément si
on vienne enlever et bien on va
récupérer un petit peu mais bon le but
c'est d'avoir à du sombre ultime et si
vous arrivez sur les box pro vous êtes
sur quoi vous êtes sur cinq heures par
butt est effectivement la même chose
avec autonomie que sur les buzz 2 l'étui
va être un peu plus faible on s'assure
18h versus 20 heures si vous enlevez la
réduction proactive vous êtes plus à
5h09 êtes à 8 heures on a gagné trois
heures ce qui est énorme et au niveau du
boîtier in 10 heures on passe de 18
heures à 28 heures alors le but c'est
pas d'enlever la réduction de bruit mais
si voyez vous n'avez plus beaucoup
d'autonomie et que vous voulez prolonger
l'expérience musicale vous pouvez le
faire vous contenterez de réduction de
bruit passive mais bon à voir dans sa
chambre vous allez coup de chara vous
savez vous le branchez cinq minutes
récupère à peu près une heure
d'autonomie sera peu près tous les
modèles donc ça c'est plutôt bien ici
vous avez bluetooth 5.0 boutou 5.0
bluetooth 5.2 les réductions de boue et
puisqu'on en parle alors une fois de
plus il y à exclure les buzz live parce
que je les trouve pas dans le dingue la
réduction de bruit que vous soyez sur un
modèle ou sans l'autre globalement bonne
elle fait bien tard c'est pas la
meilleure réduction brute que j'ai pu
écouter sur des buzz mais pour autant on
est sur un tarif qui est assez cohérent
149 euros tombé à 129 samira et là
dessus il ya aucun problème je trouve
que par contre sur les bugs procès pas
mal mais on part quand même de 229 euros
bon 179 voix c'est vraiment un tarif qui
est très très juste et très très bon là
dessus plus de 200 euros je suis pas sûr
d'y aller mais à 179 très canon ça ça ne
va dire pareil vous avez un mode
transparence lorsque vous voulez écouter
se passe autour de vous que vous êtes
dans la rue vous voulez être au courant
de ce qu'il ya autour de vous ça
fonctionne très bien et alors après faut
jouer dans tout parce que c'est vraiment
intéressant que là ça se passe
directement dans l'application regardez
je m les bucks 2 pour vous montrer dans
votre application sur vos galaxie buzz
de leur temps et je vais changer hop là
ils sont là mais peu de ceux qui sont
connectés l'expérience logiciel trouve
très très bonne ici est vachement bien
travaillé de la part de samsung que vous
soyez sur l'un des trois modèles un bien
évidemment vous avez votre niveau de
batterie réduction de bruit désactivez
le son environnement qui va venir
augmenter le son extérieur et la
réduction de bruit active hop là voilà
comme ça il va tout mais active et voilà
alors pour m'écouter parler je vais
mettre le son environnement comme ça je
m'entends bien et là je peux venir en
plus c'est ça qui va chanter recensés
soit mettre plus de volume donc là
j'avais plus de son niveau de mon cas
soit le réduire donc un côté qui est
assez pratique j'ai trois niveaux ici
voyez au niveau de la réduction active
j'ai pas d'autres niveaux ici sur mes
boxes de on va recaler sur le pro tout à
leur expérience le désactiver ensuite on
va voir le contrôles tactiles appui
prolongé ça vous explique en fait
comment ça marche appuyez vous mettez la
pause et puis deux fois morceau suivant
puis trois fin morceau précédent et
après on pouvait venir changer au niveau
des appuis prolongées pouvaient choisir
de passer xbee volume bas à gauche ou
spotify est pareil à droite pouvait
monter le volume sur spotify bref on
peut venir personnalisé ça c'est plutôt
pas mal donc c'est très complet
paramètres des écouteurs c'est pareil
vous avez ici un petit équaliseur moi je
le mets sur dynamique ça me rajoute un
petit peu de basses un peu de rondeur et
ça me booste un peu les aigus et c'est
ce que je viens préféré après j'ai pas
une option jour effectivement d'exil
lecture de à haute voix des
notifications ben voilà il ya un petit
lab avec un mode jeu qu'on peut venir
activer désactiver si on le souhaite
mais un jour accessibilité donc je
trouve que côté applicatif est vraiment
bien et très très bien faire enfin je
vous demande pour les buzz 2 mais on va
regarder ce qui se passe au niveau des
bugs pro vous allez voir que c'est aussi
tout autant intéressant donc là je mets
mes boots pro je switche alors regardez
galaxie bones pro c'est pareil je veux
avoir ici désactiver la réduction de
bruit chez le sons environnants alors la
sphère plus de niveau là je m'entends ça
n'affecte vachement n'augmentant pas
shdm en plus et là je peux le monte à
fond alors attention parce que je trouve
que la l'injection du son vous allez
avoir de l'extérieur elle est quand même
plus violente que sur les buzz 2 et sur
la réduction de bruit surtout à regarder
vous avez deux niveaux soit élevé soit
faible c'est une option qu'on n'a pas
sur les buzz donc sur les bugs prouve
aller plus loin effectivement de ce
côté-là détection de voix ça c'est un
truc qui est vachement intéressant c'est
à dire que lorsque vous commencez à
parler et bien sa voix que vous venez
parler à plat lorsque tu activera les
suppléments réduction de bruit et là je
commence à parler ça le voisin le switch
en environnement et j'arrête de parler
donc voyez il faut dix secondes en fait
alors après on a plus de choses un
blocage d appui sur les appuis prolonger
qu'est ce qui va venir se passait au
quai à droite et à gauche comme l'autre
côté by paramelle j'aime ici l'écho
l'isr en mode dynamique et sur des
notifications haute voix vous avez en
plus le audio 360 ça c'est plutôt bien
ce que vous allez venir regarder
notamment une série lorsque vous êtes
devant le son est dans vos deux oreilles
vous tournez la tête le son reste à
droite voyez on dira tout cas c'est
marrant détection de l'insertion dans
l'oreille ok je lai active et ici il ya
plus option fera plus de choses on a un
labo si avec double appui son côté des
écouteurs que j'ai pas activée mais que
je peux venir activé également ici de
l'accessibilité des mises à jour et
compagnie donc on voit qu'en fait on a
une application dans lequel on peut
avoir tous ces bugs mais qui va être
évolutif en fonction de ce que sont
capables de faire en tout cas vos buzz
alors je vous montre également pour les
boys like parce que ça c'est quand même
dommage de le faire et de pas venir
regarder ce qui se passe ici alors allez
je le prends au plat je les mets dans
mes oreilles jeu bien changé ici
j'aimais buzz live alors les buzz live
suppression active de bruit aux plages à
désactiver je le mets la voyez j'ai
juste un honneur c'est à dire que j'ai
suppression active de bruit au quai et
fouet pour moi la suppression active de
bruit elle est vraiment pas dingue donc
je peux pas venir vous le recommander
une fois de plus même pour la réduction
proactive c'est vraiment pas fou ici
vous ne pouvez pas venir amplifier le
son environnement donc lorsque vous
allez vous balader dans la rue et vous
voulez vraiment ans passe autour de vous
vous pouvez pas le faire donc ça peut
être aussi un peu embêtant pour vraiment
savoir ce qui se passe au convoi allait
courir par exemple en ville bat là on
peut pas donc je suis pas je suis pas
hyper hype et par ça et je trouve ça pas
ouf et il faut être plus à 99 euros
trois autres choses qui n'iront très
bien qui sera même mieux que ça le
contrôle tactile que je peux venir
effectivement un peut paramétrer pas de
souci là-dessus on ira moins loin mais
bon voilà ça me dérange pas bien
paramètres des écouteurs jeu voire un
petit équaliseur qui va reprendre à peu
près la même chose que les autres mais
de toute façon je n'ai pas inventé le
son que j'ai pas donc moi j'ai pas un
truc qui est dingue donc ça voilà c'est
pas c'est pas fou l'étau notification
haute voix j'ai bixby bon ok voilà après
y'a pas il n'y a pas tout d'un voyage au
dessus donc voila voila voila un peu
pour toute cette partie là donc la
partie applicative se trouve vachement
bien une fois de plus sur android est
complètement optimisé pour un smartphone
de samsung donc si vous voulez acheter
un smartphone de samsung et qu'on vous
propose ici et bien des précommandes
comme seka tout de suite avec et samsung
galaxy s 22 avec les buzz profère pas
foncer parce que vraiment ils sont très
très bien et ils iront très bien dans
l'écosystème de tous vos produits
samsung ça c'est plutôt chouette la
qualité des appels et bien je dirais
qu'elle va être corrélée à la qualité de
vos écouteurs ici on aura un truc qui
est vraiment bien une fois de plus sur
les buzz 2 les bugs pro on exclut une
fois de plus les buzz live voilà mon
retour en fait moi il ya vraiment un
produit que je trouve pas extraordinaire
et je vous le dis une fois de plus et
bien c'est les samsung galaxy buzz live
je ne les trouve pas très bons en terme
de qualité audio nous ont mis de l'arast
du sombre et actif pour avoir la
réduction google qui mais je trouve que
la qualité palal rendu pas donc c'est un
produit fricassée déceptif et je
l'exclus et je vous le recommande pas
maintenant on a deux produits alors on
va dire lâché 129 l'ag 179 ok on a quand
même 50 euros d'écart très honnêtement
j'aime beaucoup les galaxies buzz de
donc si vous avez un doute et 230 euros
on peut y aller je trouve vraiment cool
earth tour sachant qu'aujourd'hui on
peut l'être ou encore à 149 euros ça va
dépendre du revendeur mais sur le site
de samsung tout de suite en tout cas 129
euros hyper hyper canoë galaxie boxe pro
on ira plus loin entre à plus de choses
on ira paramétrer plus finement sarah du
sombre ultime on a l'eau de 360 bon
voilà dans les deux cas je les aime
beaucoup c'est toujours une question de
budget pour le vrai coup de coeur sur le
produit je trouve vraiment très bien
passe partout qui rien rempli sa
fonction sans en faire trop sont les
galaxies buzz donc je peux que vous les
recommande est ici très sympa
superdesign ichaï bien dans l'oreille
très très cool les galaxies peu de pros
sont aussi très très bon alors pensez
vraiment à venir régler à trouver la
bonne taille au niveau de votre en bout
pour se correspondent vraiment à la
taille en tout cas de votre conduit
auditif mais dans les deux cas je les
aime très très bien je la voulais
recommandé à voir maintenant ce qui vous
intéressait le budget que vous avez
galaxy 2 2 on peut y aller les yeux
fermés les pros sont très bien également
mais va lui falloir débourser un peu
plus d'argent à vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez lesquels vous aimez
est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté les
galaxies buzz live oui non pas comme moi
ce que vous avez été déçu ou pas est-ce
que vous avez les buzz de lévis prouesse
que vous êtes satisfait pas satisfait qu
est ce que vous pensez de ces
produits-là peu tous marqué en
commentaire et surtout partager votre
retour d'expérience si vous l'avez puis
si vous connaissez des écouteurs aussi
très sympa dans ses budgets la qui vous
paraissent intéressants sur android et
pourquoi pas sur un smartphone de
samsung mais voulait marquer bien
évidemment comment tu as toujours
intéressant de partager son expérience
et pour devenir conseiller les autres
voilà j'espère cette vidéo vous aura
intéressé vous aura appris des choses
c'est mon humble avis mais je vous dis
village où ces produits sont sont très
cools à vous de dire ce que vous avancez
bien évidemment en commentaire on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer parler
de samsung ya plein de choses à raconter
d'avoir pleins d'autres produits qui
vont arriver samsung mais pas que d'ici
là portez vous bien je vous embrasse
beaucoup d'amour prenez soin de vous ou
de votre famille de vos amis ce que vous
avez voilà les bisous
[Musique]